ja und das ist nicht so einfach heute
hier nach diesen nach diesen anderen
Thema am Anfang zu den Übergang zu
schaffen aber ich mache es trotzdem mal
ja ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über
Karl Lauterbach unseren
Gesundheitsminister den Lauterbach will
der jetzt Millionen Deutschen eine
viertel Impfung verabreichen also allen
den über 60 weil er sagt das hilft super
gegen Corona und das wird neueste
Studien aus Israel belegen aus Israel
wer kann dem noch widersprechen Gott sei
Dank gibt's das ja alles im Internet und
guckt man sich das mal etwas genauer an
dann sieht man dass diese Studien auch
aus Israel sehr scharf kritisiert werden
weil die sagen das hilft gar nicht gegen
die corona-infektion und auch nicht
gegen eine omicron-infektion auch nicht
bei denen die über 60 sind und die New
York Times ja eine der angesehensten
Zeitungen der Welt hat heute ebenfalls
darauf hingewiesen dass es gerade bei
dieser israelischen Studie die von Karl
Lauterbach angebracht wird und
hervorgehoben wird schwere methodische
Fehler gibt auch das ist nachzulesen nun
ist ja nicht ungewöhnlich dass es bei
verschiedenen wissenschaftlichen Studien
auch verschiedene Meinungen gibt auch
bei Wissenschaftlern ungewöhnlich ist es
aber wenn der Minister der sich um
unsere Gesundheit kümmern soll die die
Kritik an seinen Thesen gar nicht
zulässt sie auch nicht erwähnt oder wenn
überhaupt in Abrede stellt so wie er es
gemacht hat mit einem Wissenschaftler
der ihr von Bild zitiert worden ist wo
gesagt hat nur du hast es ja sowieso St
Pauli der Wissenschaftler aber mein
Freund Christian Drosten das ist der FC
Bayern wahrscheinlich hat er nicht
gewusst dass FC St Pauli bald aufsteigt
in die erste Liga wahrscheinlich und das
dem Verein ganz viele Herzen
zugewendet sind ich finde das was Karl
Lauterbach mittlerweile zeigt mit seiner
Ausgrenzung von Andersdenkenden ist eine
beispiellose Arroganz es ist die
Arroganz eines mittlerweile völlig
wirrwirkenden Ministers der im Nichte
des eigenen Scheinwerferlichts der
TV-Studios immer wieder neue Ideen sucht
um in diesen Talkshows zu bestehen die
aber nichts mit der Realität zu tun
haben das schlimme ist aber Karl
Lauterbach ist kein einfacher workkopf
erst ein ministerwirkkopf und ich finde
wirre Menschen sollten nicht an der
Spitze von Ministerien stehen
ich finde wir sollten mehr Gelassenheit
haben vor allen Dingen deshalb weil
immer geht das bei dir über diese ja ich
merke das aber diese Regierung hat einen
großen Schritt gemacht indem das
Infektionsschutzgesetz novelliert wurde
indem wir jetzt zurückfinden zur
Normalität in dem jetzt ab dem ersten
zweiten April auch die Übergangsfristen
die gesetzt wurden auslaufen und wir
damit tatsächlich wieder die Normalität
Stück für Stück in Verantwortung
zurückbekommen und deshalb sagen sie
doch das verstehe ich Ihnen auch zu das
ist die FDP da kann man sagen Bravo die
das vorangetrieben hat das können sie
sich mit ihrer Partei auf die Fahne
schreiben aber das hat doch nichts zu
tun mit dem verantwortlichen Wirken von
Herrn Lauterbach der die Impfpflicht für
uns alle noch immer durchsetzen will
also ich sage wer Normalität will der
sollte sich besser impfen und das kann
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden auch
das ist übrigen Ergebnis der politischen
Debatte im Deutschen Bundestag dass wir
keine Impfpflicht im Augenblick hier
haben sie müssen gar nicht so zurück und
daher ihr verdient und ja ich will ja
nur sagen jetzt immer auf dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister herum zu
prügeln kann man machen ich sage nur wir
sollten uns lieber mit der Frage
auseinandersetzen wie bereiten wir uns
auf den Herbst vor dazu will ich
Beiträge hören und wenn eine vierte
Impfung wenn eine vierte Unterbach für
einen Gesundheitsminister der kompetent
ist der das Beste für dieses Land will
und sie würden sagen gut dass er
Lauterbach Gesundheitsminister ist ich
glaube dass wir in sich eine gute
Regierung haben die an dieser Stelle wie
ist ihre Meinung ganz persönlich zur
Lauterbach wir reden nicht über die FDP
wir reden nicht über die Regierung nur
Lauterbach mich störte Alarmismus von
Herrn Lauterbach der stört mich aber die
Frage ob wir jetzt eine vierte Impfung
brauchen die einen selbst schützt und
welchen Beitrag die leisten kann die
müssen wir doch offen diskutieren gerade
wenn wir mal in diesem Land vor der
Welle sein wollen und nicht hinter der
Welle und da muss man natürlich auch
andere Studien zulassen da gebe ich
Ihnen völlig Recht ist ein Punkt wo ich
ihn recht gebe ich glaube aber dennoch
sollten wir jetzt mal anerkennen dass
wir den Weg in die Normalität
zurückfinden und weniger Alarmismus
machen aber dennoch hat scheuert muss
ich als Bürger sagen genau wie Nines
gesagt hat man verliert ja trotzdem die
das Vertrauen in die Regierung vor allem
auch das Vertrauen dann in Herrn
Lauterbach wenn jede Woche etwas Neues
gesagt wird wenn nie eine gewisse
Konsequenz auch da ist in dem was gesagt
wird in dem was gefordert wird in dem
was empfohlen wird dann verliert man das
Vertrauen und dann fragt man sich schon
okay was kann man jetzt glauben was kann
man nicht glauben und was ist richtig
und was ist nicht richtig
kennt jetzt einfach sagen hören sie ihm
nicht mehr zu und warten auf der
Beschlüsse der das nehmen sie auf die
Beschlüsse der Regierung die abgewogen
aus Stimmen der SPD der Grünen und der
FDP
abgestimmt ein Lösungsvorschlag sie sind
auf jeden Fall schon mal der Diplomat
der Runde den Titel vielleicht ihn jetzt
aber jetzt kommen wir doch mal zu Herrn
Bosbach und schauen mal ob Herr Bosbach
auch so diplomatisch mit Herr Lauterbach
ist
nein kann ich nicht sein es tut mir
schon fast leid dass ich das sagen muss
ich kann ihnen mittlerweile auch nicht
mehr ernst nehmen er ist ja einige
Monate gut über die Runden gekommen und
mit dem standarddruckcarbonat neueste
Studien aus Harvard exzellente Fachleute
kenne ich alle persönlich und er hat
dann den Eindruck einer überragenden
Kompetenz vermittelt und da waren ja
viele froh endlich einer der nicht nur
Gesundheitspolitik macht sondern der
auch Mediziner ist und der richtig
Ahnung vom Thema hat Klammer auf im
Gegensatz zum Familien Amtsinhaber Jens
Spahn Klammer zu dann gab es für mich
ein ein wirkliches Erlebnis nämlich Karl
Lauterbach bekam im ZDF Morgenmagazin
aber im Leben nicht mit gerechnet ein
paar kritische Fragen gestellt nämlich
aber nicht zu oft Alarmismus verbreiten
würde daraufhin Lauterbach das war so
vor zwei drei Monaten nee das ist die
Kampagne der Bild-Zeitung daraufhin habe
ich mir mein Tablet geschnappt und habe
nur zwei Wörter auch
reingetippt Lauterbach warnt und dann
ploppte es an allen Mann ich habe ja
fast ein Kabelbrand bekommen im Tablet
es gibt 50 60 Fälle vor denen Lauterbach
gewarnt hat und dann habe ich etwas
anderes gemacht ich habe mal die
Diagnosen und Prognosen von Klaus Stöhr
von Hendrik streek daneben gelegt die
waren viel genauer als das was uns Karl
Lauterbach erzählt hat aber eins war
klar lädst du lauter machen eine Sendung
ein hast du am nächsten Tag eine fette
Schlagzeile weil er mit Sicherheit
wieder vor irgendetwas warnen wird dann
hat er noch am Rande Oster vergangenen
Jahres die spanischen Ärzte und
Virologen mal einmal eben für
komplettsach und kundig erklärt die
Zahlen würde er überhaupt nicht glauben
da würde nur geschummelt warum ist er
Gesundheitsminister geworden weil er zu
dem bekanntesten populärsten Politikern
gehört das stimmt weil ich ihn sozusagen
das Votum der Fernsehzuschauer ins
Gesundheitsministerium getragen hat
es hatte schon seinen Grund warum Karl
Lauterbach nie eine Regierungsamt in der
hatte und wenn er meint dass er jetzt
die Lösung ich bin einer der Kandidaten
nicht nur weil ich über 60 bin sondern
in wenigen Tagen werde ich ja 70 über
Karl Lauterbach nach zwei Jahren bin ich
erkrankt einen Monat nach meiner vierten
Impfung wo kann man das ich bin ich bin
Firma geimpft wo kann man natürlich
sagen das war kein schwerer Verlauf was
auch stimmt Klammer auf Gott sei Dank
Klammer zu aber so zu tun
ich habe immer Impfung verstanden
sterile Immunität wenn du dich dagegen
impfen lässt dann kannst du nicht mehr
daran erkrankt jedenfalls im Regelfall
das stimmt schon lange nicht mehr
Bosbach ich glaube sie haben also alle
sitzen hier zustimmend wahrscheinlich
auch schon ins Lagerhaus aber
rübergewächst einfach Lager wegzukommen
meine These einfach nur noch mal
unterstrichen hat wenn Normalität will
sollte sich besser impfen ganz einfach
unterstrichen indem er gesagt hat er hat
einen milden Verlangen gehabt
ich bin kein Impfgegner das will ein
Gegner eines im Zwangs ja das teile ich
das zu der Lauterbach teilen Sie auch
was Herr Bosbach gesagt hat den
Impfzwang
wir sind natürlich so weit dass wir
jetzt mittlerweile uns einmal
auseinandersetzen müssen mit der Drosten
Regel die er sagt am besten schütze ich
mich wenn ich dreimal geimpft bin und
dreimal infiziert am besten schwer dann
bin ich wahrscheinlich so Drosten
Originalton für mehrere Jahre gut
geschützt was das jetzt mit der vierten
Impfung bedeutet ob ich mich jetzt auch
noch danach nach Drosten ein viertes Mal
infizieren muss auch ein bisschen am
besten schwer um dann für mehrere Jahre
geschützt zu sein weiß ich nicht ich
kann nur sagen
Lauterbach und sein Haus sollte sich mal
intensiv auseinandersetzen mit den
kritischen Studien sie sollten den Mut
haben diese kritischen Studien auch zu
der vierten Impfung zu besprechen zu
bewerten und die Menschen zu sagen was
es damit auf sich hat denn in diesen New
York Times ist ja auch jetzt nicht St
Pauli Nachricht immer mit Lauterbach zu
sprechen der solche kritischen Studien
ja immer nur verunglimpft dann auch da
steht ganz klar drin dass die über 60 in
der nichts davon haben und ich finde es
einfach unredlich wenn man solche Kritik
ausblendet sie wie den Virologen der wie
gesagt von Bild hier zitiert worden ist
verächtlich macht nur weil ihm nur weil
einem die Meinung nicht passt das ist
kann man vielleicht machen als
Abgeordneter in Talkshows aber nicht
mehr als Minister